wir schon gemeinsam auf die Live-Bilder
und auch das wieder Bilder die besonders
berühren muss man sagen mit verneigten
Kopf viele Blumen dort auf dem Auto der
Queen und es sind die letzten Meter
jetzt Richtung St George Chapel das sind
noch einmal über die Besonderheit dieses
Ortes sprechen das ist Windsor dort hat
man glückliche Stunden verbracht das hat
man Hochzeiten gefeiert dort hat man
aber auch viel Trauer erlebt Tanja ja
ist vor anderthalb Jahren im April
letzten Jahr das ist ja hier in der
Prinz Philip der geliebte Ehemann der
Queen beerdigt worden beigesetzt worden
die Bilder des Trauergottesdienst damals
waren gänzlich anders als wir das heute
erleben es war ja auch mitten in der
corona-krise es durften kaum Gäste
eingeladen werden die königliche Familie
saß getrennt voneinander in
verschiedenen Reihen die Königin saß
ganz alleine und jeder Druck Mundschutz
also das ist für mich auch ein Bild was
ich für immer einprägen wird wenn ich an
die Königin denke wie einsam und wie
klein sie damals in dieser Kirchen war
es ganz alleine die Familie saß hier
gegenüber sie wollte bewusst alleine
sitzen und ihr letzter Blick eben auf
den Sarg ihres geliebten Mannes das ist
für immer ein Bild was bleiben wird und
natürlich auch schöne Momente also die
Hochzeit von Prinz Harry und seiner
Meghan wurde hier ja auch gefeiert und
damals so schien es zumindest war ja
alles noch gut und man freute sich
darauf dass Kate und William jetzt
endlich Unterstützung bekommen von Harry
mit seiner Frau und ja die fährt vor wie
man sie ja nannte und damals dachte
glaube ich die ganze Königsfamilie ja
alles wird gut und innerhalb weniger
Jahre hat sich ja alles leider zum
Negativen gedreht wenn wir speziell
jetzt auf Harry und Meghan gucken
ein Bild sehe ich gerade und wir
versuchen das jetzt einfach mal weil das
möchte ich mit allen Teilen dafür drehe
ich einfach mal meinen Laptop um das ist
ein Bild das ist mich sehr berührt hat
Entschuldigung an die Kamera Männern ich
versuche es einmal so das zu machen dass
es jetzt nicht ganz so spiegelt aber wir
haben viel über die Emotionen gesprochen
in dieser Sendung und über die
Besonderheit des Prinzessin Charlotte
und Prinz George da sind und hier sehen
wir Prinzessin schadet sie ist sieben
Jahre alt und das ist etwas das hat
abseits der Kameras dann im Stadt
gefunden der bricht natürlich dieses
Kind dann doch mal in Tränen aus ihre
Urgroßmutter ganglang als sie sie
genannt ist gestorben und natürlich
Trauer als auch dieses Kind abseits von
Protokoll und von Pflicht und von der
Größe des Moments ganz menschlich um
ihre Urgroßmutter beziehen ich finde
also mir ist Mutter zerreißt es da total
das Herz und man möchte die kleine
schadet am liebsten selbst in den Arm
nehmen und gleichzeitig ist das aber
vielleicht auch so eine Botschaft an die
Menschen da draußen wie authentisch die
Royal Family ist wie echt sie mit
Gefühlen umgeht denn natürlich Kinder
sind nicht kalkulierbar sind nicht
planbar sind nicht in einem Protokoll
einquetschtbar natürlich was Sicherheit
Wohlleben mit William und Kate auch klar
dass sie Emotionen wieder kontrollieren
können noch so hoffe ich kontrollieren
wollen dieser Kleinkinder also ich
glaube ihm auf keinen Fall dass Sie die
das Emotionen kontrollieren wollen sie
wollen Sie vielleicht beginnen ein
bisschen kontrollieren indem sie sagen
bitte keine Grimassen schneiden aber
danach ich glaube was was wir Mütter
auch kennen ist dass das Kinder auch
wahnsinnig unglücklich sind wenn sie
merken dass die Eltern unglücklich sind
und wenn was die beiden natürlich
gemerkt haben gerade heute Mittag dass
alle um sie herum gerade trauern und
dass die Emotionen bei allen weil ich
glaube es gibt nicht einen Menschen der
heute im dabei teilgenommen hat der
nicht emotional geworden ist und das
natürlich kriegen die Kinder das mit und
natürlich wird auch immer wieder klar
gemacht worden sein da liegt deine
Gangnamen drin in diesem Sarg sie ist
jetzt nicht mehr da und das ist auch
wenn ein siebenjähriges Mädchen
natürlich ein ein Bild eines Sarges das
ist sehr schwer darüber hinwegzukommen
aber es gehört dazu und sie werden gut
darauf vorbereitet gewesen sein und
natürlich haben Kate und William gut
daran getan den kleinen Louis nicht
mitzunehmen weil er hätte es wirklich
noch nicht verstanden während die Queen
da schauen wir auch in babygesichter
auch die sind jetzt natürlich da und
dürfen an diesem historischen Moment
teilnehmen aber müssen wir auch noch und
nachdem was so gut geklappt hat hier
technisch bricht das auch einfach noch
einmal um müssen wir auch über die
Echtheit was für Werbeblöcke werden wir
angezeigt alles in Ordnung dieser Tränen
sprechen das nämlich ist Meghan diese
Fotos sehen Sie jetzt gerade hier bei
Bild live und natürlich auch auf bild.de
Meghan die sich da verstohlen eine Träne
aus dem Gesicht wischt auch darüber
müssen wir hier natürlich Bettina von
Schimmelmann Tanja mai sprechen Meghan
eine ganz besondere Rolle an diesen Tag
denn eigentlich ist ja auftragen
natürlich sich im Hintergrund zu halten
und gleichzeitig schaut auch die Welt
auf sie und wie sie ihre Rolle erfüllt
wie sehr glaubt ihr also diesen Tränen
ich weiß du willst zuerst so dass
war wirklich die Meghan als sie als
Schauspielerin die ersten Dates hatte
mit Prinz Harry ich war beglückt von
dieser Beziehung aber ich bin es ich
gebe zu ich bin es nicht mehr und
natürlich haben wir auch vorhin unter
den Kollegen auch über dieses eine Bild
gesprochen man könnte jetzt böse sagen
sie hat jetzt nach Stunden es geschafft
sich eine Träne aus dem Auge zu drücken
und es wirkt eben sehr gestellt dieses
Bild und man hat ja gesehen in der
Kirche in Westminster Abbey da sind
Tränen geflossen es sind Tränen
geflossen bei King Charles es sind auch
Tränen geflossen man hat gemerkt auch
William war sehr ergriffen auch der
kleine Prinz george hat geweint also hat
sich auch verstohlen Tränen weggewicht
aber diese Träne jetzt von Meghan tut
mir leid ich sage sie ist nicht echt
Bettina du kannst widersprechen aber ich
glaube das schwer fallen sagen wir so
ich war von Anfang an kein großer Fan
von Meghan weil ich einfach so viele von
diesen Meghans in Hollywood
kennengelernt habe so viele von diesen
jungen Mädchen die wirklich ausgezogen
sind um das berühmte Glück zu finden und
zwar das berühmte Glück in einem reichen
schönen erfolgreichen Mann und dann
immer wieder natürlich die die Aussagen
von ihr Seite gar nicht gewusst wer
harry ist aber natürlich auf der anderen
Seite stand sie vor dem Buckingham
Palace in ihrer Jugend also ich finde
sie sehr kalkulierbar und ich finde auch
dieses Foto ist sehr kalkuliert sie weiß
wir haben es vorhin glaube ich mal
erwähnt 4 Milliarden Menschen schauen zu
wie viele hunderte von Fotografen werden
davor vor dem ja vor den Kirchen gewesen
sein sie weiß es ganz genau so was jeder
Schritt wird für ihr Beobachtung sie
hatte noch nie noch nie so eine große
Bühne wie heute
bisher muss man sagen nutzt sie die noch
relativ zurückhaltend das können wir
auch noch ganz anders aber natürlich
Tanja schüttelt schon im Kopf natürlich
ist auch dieser Tag noch junge
[Musik]